CHANCE?
I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE.
I WOULD SAY, WHAT ARE YOU NUTS?
>> Tucker: JOY BEHAR HAS A
MUCH MORE NORMAL PERSONAL LIFE
THAN YOU DO.
CHRIS, THAT'S THE RESISTANCE
RIGHT THERE.
>> SHE'S GOT A VERY NICE LIFE,
TRUST ME.
>> Tucker: I KNOW HER TOO.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S THE FACE OF
THE RESISTANCE.
FOR THE LAST YEAR, WE'VE BEEN
HEARING HE'S DEGRADING THE
COUNTRY AND I GET WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, BUT THE SAME TIME, THE
LEFT HAS DEGRADED ITSELF TO THE
POINT THAT RUSSIAN COLLUSION HAS
SOMEHOW MORPHED INTO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT AND SEX LIVES
IN ALL THIS STUFF I CAN'T
DESCRIBE ON TV.
ARE YOU PROUD OF THAT?
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT THE
CONVERSATION TO BE?
>> THIS IS FUN TO TALK ABOUT --
>> Tucker: WHAT'S THE POINT OF
TALKING ABOUT IT?
>> I THINK PEOPLE LOVE THE
SALACIOUS DETAILS, BUT I DON'T
CARE WHAT THE PRESIDENT DOES
WITH HIS PERSONAL LIFE EVEN IF
THAT IS TRUE.
I CARE ABOUT THE RUSSIANS MAY
HAVE COMPROMISED ON HIM.
I CARE HOW HE PAID FOR IT JUST
LIKE WE CARE ABOUT ELIOT SPITZER
PAYING FOR IT.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Tucker: I DID NOT CARE HOW
WE PAID FOR IT AND THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT SHAFTED HIM USING
LAWS FROM THE WAR ON TERROR AND
THE PATRIOT ACT.
I DESPISE ELIOT SPITZER PAID
WHAT THEY DID TO HIM WAS
HORRIBLE.
IT WAS A TOTAL ABUSE OF POWER,
JUST LIKE THIS.
YOU MAY NOT CARE ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF TRUMPS PERSONAL LIFE,
BUT HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT ROBERT
MUELLER DISPATCHING FBI'S TO
BREAK INTO HIS LAWYER'S OFFICE?